the doctor's office shout out to the dog
we
we we went skydiving shout out to the
doc heck yeah we went to uh
dinner what kind of doctor is he
you know i mean come on it can't take
that long
he's probably the kind of doctor that
has a billboard no he's not definitely
not what kind of doctor is he matt i
know you know i mean
he's you know i i i don't know what kind
of doctor
you never asked in that i mean you know
you know what listen what am i supposed
to say doctor feel good
i mean i can ask him what kind of dog no
i mean i just thought
i thought you [ __ ] knew no
i do what kind of doctor question mark
read my super chats bro so anyway what
if he's a plastic surgeon and you never
asked him what he is or he does hair
transplants
because we would have come up because we
talked about we talked about the hair
maybe that's why he's giving you all
this money to like
seed that idea let me go just like spend
this money back on the doctor and a
little bit more
huh like he does hair transplants no he
doesn't so he's giving you this money
doesn't do you're gonna go spend it back
on him no that wouldn't make any sense
i don't understand i think it makes
perfect sense i don't understand that
logic
it makes perfect sense he's trying to
recoup
when you think about it you're trying to
recoup yeah i think
that's what did he message you back yet
no
it's a doctor no he's probably playing
with his kids or on the computer or
the chat i mean he's in the chat
watching the podcast so why didn't you
ask him what kind of doctor
he's throwing money at you like you work
at mons venus
i'll show you throw me and you put
enough money in it i will
people really want you to eat [ __ ]
tonight huh people want you to eat
danny's poop
that's what people are saying that's
been the main topic of the chat it is
you know it's amazing how how disgusting
these [ __ ] are and
cruel and mean they say it's not amazing
they say horrible things
they want to see it they want all the
action but they don't want you for it
yeah
that's not action that's disgusting it
depends on who you ask
the internet's a weird place man
[ __ ] place got weird when i was going
what the [ __ ] happened oh what were you
just talking about i [ __ ] forgot
um oh yeah oh yeah okay you're getting
here the guy oh yeah why would you admit
to being a rat or being a soft white guy
yeah he's going off
no he didn't he didn't actually say that
he just keeps going and going and going
he just keeps you know and i'm like okay
well you know um
clearly we're cut from a different cloth
so i said so anyway and i'm like do you
want to keep
talking about this he's like no what i'm
saying is this and this and he's going
on
you know i'm saying you with this you
with that i'm like yeah
you so so you saying you're going to get
caught he goes
you're going to get caught you get
caught doing something now first he said
it's your duty as a soldier or something
along those lines i was like
soldier yeah like if you're a soldier
and you get caught
and they torture you you gotta hold out
so you don't tell on your platoon and i
went um
am i a soldier in this
i'm not a soldier have you ever seen the
movie batman you ever heard of the joker
yeah that's me
i don't know about soldiers i mean i i i
just
it always kills me these guys that are
selling crack
in the or they're selling crack in the
park
you know to pregnant women and then they
get caught and you think that this guy's
not gonna tell on you or he's gonna hold
strong nobody's telling me you
you're just a scumbag bro you're selling
[ __ ] crack
yeah and you're you're selling crack or
you're kicking in people's doors
or you're committing fraud or you're
doing
scams and you get caught and now you
have principles
you're just a scumbag or someone else
gets caught
you decided don't
tell on me i won't tell on you are you
serious that's the line
you're [ __ ] ripping off little old
ladies pension funds yeah
what are you talking about yeah but
we're bros pros
there's no street code your bro is gonna
[ __ ] your girl when you're gone and take
all your [ __ ]
that's what's gonna happen right right
that's not you know
so i'm and i remember i said i go so i'm
supposed to go to prison for 26 years
and he was like you know i'm like i'm
not going to prison for 26 years i'm not
doing it
he's playing fortnite on your account on
your couch his feet on your table he's
spending all your v-bucks
i know a guy that got out of prison
and told the guy to go to his go to my
he actually
sets the guy up like you can stay i talk
to my wife she'll let you stay
in like the spare room until you get a
job and get this and get that
listen two months later he calls he
calls
he calls and the wife says don't call
anymore
i'm with so and so now the guy you set
up in prison
that your wife's going to help out that
you're going to help out your wife's
been running with you for four or five
years
now he's [ __ ] your wife this is your
buddy
that's what they're they're all scumbags
now if you're a guy
if you're a guy and you're a stand-up
guy and you go to a pen
now i can understand you telling me i
didn't say anything not because i'm a
good guy because you're not
but i didn't say anything because i was
afraid that when i went to the
went to the pen they might kill me if i
showed up with paperwork that said i
snitched on everybody
okay i got it i understand you go into a
pen you can't say anything
you know what it's like you're going to
a california pen you're just [ __ ]
done
i'll take the [ __ ] 10 years so but
the difference is that it's it's that or
my family's in danger i know that these
guys will kill my family because i know
they've killed my family before
but guess what that's not me
danny's if i [ __ ] told on danny he
ain't killing nobody
danny's not gonna bust a grate the worst
danny's gonna do is sue me he's right
and
that's it and no but i have a few people
i could pay some money too that would
really not make your life very pleasant
i mean and i have a really good friend
he said
500 bucks who would uh burn your house
down
what a neurosurgeon
he's a neurosurgeon a neurosurgeon he
sounds like what he's a brain surgeon
i mean i guess it's that's what holy
[ __ ] she's got so much damn money i
don't believe it prove it
listen he's got like listen he if he
could do brain surgery he could do your
hair transplant that's right
that's true his wife's car is like 150
000 um uh was it like a land rover or
something or
range rover or something it was his
wife's car wow
what's he driving i i don't know he was
like in the shop or something i forget
he's like yes rory's in the shop picked
it up ferrari it's always in the shop
so yeah so yeah that podcast did not go
well
he was disgusted by me this really broke
my heart too because i thought we were
going to be friends
but then he left and when they were
leaving when he was leaving in a
cameraman
the cameraman couldn't stop where did
you guys film it at in my hotel room
in your hotel room yeah in downtown it
was the uh
was it was i would say the hilton hilton
hilton
airport checkers no hilton checkers in
downtown
really nice hotel so um
we do the whole thing they gather all
their stuff up they go to leave
and when they're leaving this camera man
never he never he couldn't stop smiling
like he was just he this guy and i kept
saying like boy you're really upset
about this well i don't believe in that
um believe i said well i understand you
don't believe in it but you know what
happens
even after you stopped rolling you guys
were still talking about this oh yeah he
he he stood up he's packing up his stuff
i go you really seem upset i said it
like five times
really you really seem upset by this
well i just i just this i i just don't
feel
uh right i i would not do that i
wouldn't so i understand i understand
and he's like you know and even here's
the problem is that when we were on film
and we were arguing
we weren't really arguing because there
was he was so animated i thought there's
a good chance this guy [ __ ] swings on
me and
and let me let me be perfectly clear if
he had swung on me
i wouldn't have survived it i mean right
this is a
big [ __ ] guy you've been calling the
neuro doctor
he couldn't have helped the doctor
couldn't have helped i mean
so i'm sitting there so he's making
these ridiculous
giving me these ridiculous scenarios
what's the doctor saying
um what'd he say he said you're an
[ __ ] for not telling me you were
going to be on the podcast
yeah why wouldn't you tell him i didn't
tell him because
well i don't have to [ __ ] tell him
this i can tell him right now i didn't
say anything because i
why didn't i i didn't really know why
you did you told me yesterday yes
i told
huh i think monday we decided to do this
monday or tuesday i believe it was
monday night well he knows
i told you right after occasions
he's a busy guy he's flying to l.a and
sure he's on vice now
oh you're on vice now tell everybody how
you did a [ __ ] uh documentary for
vice
it wasn't documentary i'm a i'm an
expert scammer
yeah you are on on on mice so i wanted
john madden
of scamming so i'm one of the listen it
was that was a pretty bad shoot like i
mean
they had me doing all kinds of like okay
can you go would you mind looking out
the windows i'm like
like through the blinds and i go like
some kind of peeper well
you know like uh just some yeah b-roll
i'll be a peeper let's do this they did
a documentary on lanny papho and he was
telling me
that they spent like two full days
shooting b-roll like him walking through
the park
sitting at the on the bench feeding
pigeons you understand i'm only they
told me these things are like three or
four minutes long they're like you're
literally only going to be on camera for
a minute or two
on three different episodes took six
hours yeah
yeah so professional
so listen when the cameraman is leaving
right matching cameras thank you doc
hey can your doc is he certified can he
install the uh
can he install the uh i thought you had
to watch [ __ ] a game or something
gotta go watch tv
no we got uh the nba the last game of
the season the nba finals
boy i'm animating what am i doing lebron
james versus miami heat
i'm all like [ __ ] waving my arms and
are you watching yourself i just saw
myself waving my arm get out of your
head
um i forget what i was gonna say
you're just so in love with yourself
it's like when you look at yourself
you're just oh my god
what the [ __ ] it's me skye why it's matt
huh
are you serious what is this all right
should we wrap this up
by the insanity bye it's insanity and
this was the shortest matt pox
matt cox oh here we go podcast in
history oh the permanent kid
tell you what oh
check oh okay everybody thank you
matt cox's paypal is matt cox69
gmail.com cox69 you can contribute to
his hairline he needs seven thousand
dollars for his neck surgery even though
i think that hairline looks pretty good
it looks pretty solid decent very decent
i think it's better than my hairline
definitely better than mine i've never
seen a hair out of place on that
beautiful head of yours
that's what 7k gets you the tan even
goes into the hair the two of you are
you guys are i mean with all three of
you guys
because normally like when you get you
know like you get a really close fade
sometimes it's like white
oh yeah yeah like your hand goes all the
way into your head yeah
how do you get that tan so perfect and
like in your hair
you die your dye hair your scalp is tan
so are you 24 7 when you're out in
public is your hair slicked back like
that all the time whenever you go out
i mean i don't even know it was slicked
back i just put that together
you clearly gelled it back you don't
wear a hat when you pay for hair no
no i don't wear a hat i wear a hat
because this is like a lux it's a you
know it's just there like
if you pay for it you're so young and
you have all your hair yeah i have a
thick head of hair
how would you think his how do you grade
his hairline oh it's
it's it's amazing he could you listen
your hairline
his hairline is is farther back than
yours
he's got a good hairline he's got a good
hairline he can use a touch up
how do you think a little scruffy do you
think he needs a
surgery not on the hairline but maybe on
the nose and the teeth
this would be wasted money up here it's
a bad investment
gotta wait and see if it's done no but
how do you eat the tan how do you get
the tan so
i didn't even think i'm tan am i tan no
like he was talking about how the tan
perfectly hits the hairline it even goes
past it goes in it blends
probably because it's so thin the sun
hits my scalp
science science that's
crazy the solar the solar flares the uv
penetrates the
the hair transplants and hits the scalp
perfectly activates it
activates it oh my god
all right i think we've had enough yeah
well you got to go well the game's
starting
we can watch it who's winning it hasn't
even started but who's going to win the
heat
is that who you want to win you want the
heat to win
i only want the heat to win because i
bet him 20 bucks the heat would win
and i really like jimmy jesus
jimmy jesus jimmy buckets aka jimmy
jesus
they're the underdog and i think they
can come back three to one like lebron
did versus the golden state warriors in
2016.
but i think lebron's my my my head's
saying lebron's gonna win my heart's
saying heat please win
we'll see some turmoil but i'll probably
lose 20 bucks but thank god the neuro
doctor
donated about five hundo yeah thanks for
the chicken fingers tonight
yeah thanks doctor eating chicken finger
is going to help pay for matt cox's
dinner
i always pay for matt cox's dinner at
the podcast matt cox any last words
buy a book and sign and subscribe to my
channel matt cox
and uh inside true crime books on amazon
books on amazon danny's gonna put the
put it in the link
yeah put the link but in the description
[ __ ] bro
i'm so tired shark in the housing pool
oh my god
housing pool and it's insanity boom who
just did this
buy some [ __ ] buy it [ __ ]
[Laughter]